it is the grand opening of resorts world
it's just a few hours away now about
[Music]
14 if you're counting uncle holmen got a
look at some of the incredible dining
options in store
hey bianca it looks beautiful in there
hey good morning alice good morning john
one of the big things that i'm excited
about tonight as far as when it comes to
that party is the food and you know
las vegas we do it right when it comes
to food and they're doing it right
as we look here at resorts world and you
can have food delivered all over this
property because of their
great partnership with grubhub and one
thing that really stands out is just how
many food
options this property has the food court
spans almost an entire length of the
casino it's called
famous foods and it has an asian street
vibe with 16 restaurants
and a hidden speakeasy you know we got
one of those
so there are seven signature restaurants
nine casual eateries and several other
bars and lounges
and we actually sat down with billy
richardson of the owner of marigold
lobster and burgers
a new american restaurant and he says
it's nice to see a resort opening at a
time like this
we're super excited to be here it's
after everything that we've gone through
it's great that vegas is opening up a
new big building says
you know when we open these buildings in
town it draws a lot of attention
and and that's what we need we need we
want people to come here and enjoy
and one thing you notice is that most of
the food options are
right off of the casino floor you don't
have to go far
to have a tasty bite and again you can
be anywhere on the property and with the
touch of your phone grub hub
it will deliver one of those food
options one of the 40 food options
right to you and also we eat grades we
like to party
and we like to party outside yeah we're
going to talk about the pool coming
up in just a few minutes and just the
amazing features about the pool that
they have
because it's it's right over there you
can actually see it they've got trees
over there and it's of course the
cabanas
day parties night parties what's going
to be popping out here